le département vous présente terre de
trail la descente du maïdo est une
libération celle d'avoir survécu à
mafate
après la forêt les boucans au milieu des
champs de géraniums peuvent surprendre
un moment hors du temps avec daniel gas
raid
bravo bravo on croise alors trois après
ses abats pourrait carré comme ça non
nous allons en eux daniel vasella
mission sous silence et on fout soeur
sans souci
[Musique]
de grasse matinée
ce label représente à main nue de pialat
six ans s'établissant au camping il va
d'ailleurs avoir allaité millions de
titres hybrides bas dit total la food
and sand au prêtre a pété de rire on va
pas remonter un bep ou 17 ans loos
après bordeaux n'a plus qu'à planter ou
faire des plantes médicinales aussi la
maladie
mais ça il faut tenir pour parler il
faut toujours faire passer ça il soit de
petite enfance est où psa au pied tout
[Musique]
35 boucan dans la forêt départementaux
de manial gérés par des gardes médiateur
de la spa d'éden
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai d'ailleurs combien de la minus
entier par département
parce qu'avant mais il y en avait un
vieux sentiers escarpés comme tim thomas
ou te croire tout cela est multi mode
google books le début il ya les mafatais
bas il y appelle chemin du monde parle
est ce qu'on va continuer à apprécier et
sa mort a précisé théo bon courage et
bonne chance pour la suite
harvey a war nous conviendrait de courir
dont 27 ans brann et ouvrez vos allées
des revues ça mais bon allez bon courage
rien c'est le département vous a
présenté terre de trail